My nose was not running!
Just before stream, I'm like...
I can't...
Stop my nose!
Hold on.
Yummy.
Throat spray.
Sorry, I'm so... I'm so nose runny today.
Sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze.
I don't think I'll sneeze.
I did do a big sneeze earlier.
Maybe I will sneeze.
Who knows?
Welcome everybody.
Howdy dody.
Howdy.
Hello.
Welcome to Berry Burry.
Berry.
No, I don't think I'm sick.
Maybe...
Dust.
Maybe dust.
Thank you so much for
the...
Where this game, we are...
I turned off some settings, by the way, if you are familiar
with this game.
It has like a fake VHS setting, and then also something else
I turned off.
Oh, the colors.
It was like overly saturated, and I desaturated them a
little bit.
For your viewing pleasure.
Oh, yeah, I'm sick in the head.
I'm sick in the head.
But this game is like not a horror game, I think.
It's like a creepy cozy kind of the vibes are a little off,
right?
This stuff also kills bitrate.
I know!
That's why I also turned it off.
But basically we are getting berries and we throw them in a
hole and then we get money.
And then we use the money to buy upgrades on how to collect
more berries and more money.
Why are we burying berry bug?
She deserves it.
Bagamangosteen, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
No, this is not berry bug.
This is berry delicious.
Berry berry fruits and just fruits, no veggies.
Have fun with the game.
Sadly, it's snowing yet again where I am right now.
February snow.
That checks, that tracks.
I feel like most places get snow until like April.
You know?
Akira!
It's your birthday today!
Would've stopped by, watched my OC.
Hope you have a good stream.
Muay, muay, boo!
Help him!
Yeah.
Salupi, welcome back.
David, welcome back.
Chiloncha, welcome back.
Burying, burying into berries, berries.
You guys probably can't even hear me.
even hear the ambiance it's so low even for me the birds the
birds are singing the sun is shining and we are going to
bury some berries not berry bug though hello welcome back oh
no not welcome back but yes welcome back but thank you for
the fine good to thank you Neptune welcome back thank you
yeah let's get into it it's kind of loud now Oh, press E to
pick up berries and objects.
Left mouse to throw, right to drop.
Oh, look at her.
Oh, put a berry in the hole.
Pick up the coin.
Repeat until bedtime.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, oh.
Money falleth from the sky.
Oh, oh, I'm slow.
Pick, pick up.
Oh, I have to E.
E.
oh oh no no no i can't fall in there can i oh i'm slow i'm
too slow oh my god please pick up my money my cash money why
i'm single dollar let's go great i'm made thank you so much
for the pockets thank you oh oh no is that the time of
bedtime one more please oh i can run
Spooky.
Minto feeding us berries.
Are you guys down there?
Bo boy.
Barely.
Wednesday beckons.
Oh.
I think it's trying to eat me.
Go to bed and bank your money.
You don't want to stay up too late.
I think the thing will try to eat me if I don't.
Look at this guy.
Oh, he's staring at me.
What's this?
We have a very...
tired looking uh radio here buy
a berry buddy for one dollar make friends with a blueberry
look at all these things fifty thousand dollars upgrade
flower to bush oh grows three berries
five million dollars
Oh, it keeps going!
Oh yeah!
I'll grow some berries We're gonna grow them and grow them
and throw them in the hole We're gonna grow them and throw
them in the hole Oh yeah We're gonna grow them and throw
them into the hole We're gonna grow them and throw them into
the hole We're gonna grow them and throw them into the hole
We're gonna grow them and throw them into the hole We're
gonna make money Money, money, money, money, money, money,
it's not thank you!
5 million unlocks the star key, the key to happiness.
Sledgehammer for smashing stuff.
What do we need to smash?
Or pass.
We pass.
We are waking up.
Complete your first day, Sprout.
I like the, uh...
There's a...
Oh, good job.
Did you know you can hold down E to pick up coins easier?
much oh there's our berry buddy and he is running over there
and producing more blueberries for us i forgot that i can
run but we need him over here hello berry buddy oh my gosh
oh he's a little stupid that's okay we love him not like
that what's what june oh june i thought he would like put
Apparently not.
Oh, oh, I feel like I'm getting awfully close to falling in
the hole.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Time for bed.
Oh, here.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, the day is so short.
Ow!
A golden blueberry!
No!
Oh, it is starting to move towards me.
It's kind of freaky.
What happens if I fall in?
Probably die, right?
Oh, I can afford one more thing.
Unlock Star Orb Generator.
Create Star Orbs from berries put in the hole.
Oh, yeah.
This must be that, right?
Okay.
Want to find out?
Yeah, let's find out.
Oh, wait.
Let's buy this.
Our next currency.
One way to find out.
Oh.
Check Sunny's Sunny.
beams for the remaining daytime oh pick up berries what is
this every berry put down the hole has a chance to spawn a
star orb shatter them to the collector power here i go am i
skinny enough guys i think i'm kind of thick i can't fit i
can't fit down the hole well good to know i guess unless oh
yeah we're gonna we're gonna make big bucks one dollar at a
time we'll eventually did he just knock over the what do you
do with berry buddy oh my god you're you're causing a ruckus
oh my gosh we have so many berries though i wish i could
pick up more than one at a time i have to be at least i can
get my oh no another one it's five million for the key to
happiness i thought
free the key to happiness i thought they said money can't
buy happiness no i missed the store i don't have enough
money for anything another golden berry we'll get one this
time for sure you're producing we're all producing oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah wait there's a star how do i shatter it oh
what does this do anyway oh we got some tunes we got some
tunes oh yeah oh yeah they're a multi berry pickup plasmid i
need it at least it looks like the coins kind of like they
they um what's the word they can't go into the hole it seems
they the hole rejects the coins already oh my gosh no son no
please my my berry son the hole grows a larger it's so
ominous why does it take over the whole screen the hole
grows larger can i fit in it now wait we'll try oh we'll
save our money Yeah, maybe now I can jump in.
Here we go.
Oh, God.
Rewind.
Rewind to the beginning, resetting your money and upgrades.
Retains your Barry buddies banked star orbs and gain plus
25% Barry growth speed.
I had to for science.
Unlocks the star wand used to upgrade.
Barry buddy we should save up for that no but bubble
surround yourself in a bibble to float oh it's not a bubble
it's a bibble like cookie clicker prestige mode yeah exactly
oh my gosh I think I would play this all day oh I'm a fan
okay okay can I get another can I get another golden golden
berry please okay but I have to be careful I don't want to
fall in we're on we're on we're not on easy mode every
anymore everybody oh man I want the hole to be so big bigger
bigger bigger what can I pick up other stuff like like rocks
no oh excuse me excuse me June.
June level 3 star.
Is that what it said?
No, already!
How old am I to be so...
I'm just... My day ends so quickly.
Oh!
There were two stars!
I missed the other one.
Dang.
I almost went to bed without collecting my cash money.
Does the whole look bigger to you guys, or is it just me?
I mean, I know this said the whole growth.
But...
Big Minky Love, thank you!
I'm planning to cosplay you at Dokomi this year.
And I want to stop smoking for it because I know you hate
it.
Uh-huh.
And don't want to get any smoke smell in the cosplay.
But quitting is so hard.
Mazi!
I know, it's really hard, but...
You're...
You are stronger.
You're stronger!
Also, Vanessa, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Suck up and shoot out multiple berries!
Oh, I think we need that.
I think once we have this, then we can get the star wand
easily.
Vacuum.
How do I use?
Where's my vacuum?
Oh.
Old control to charge the vacuum.
Fire to fling out.
Wait, oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Wait.
Can I suck it?
How do I suck?
it how do i suck is it here hold e to suck with the vacuum
oh it's it's huge then control or oh
oh this is huge this is a game changer this is game changing
oh can i get rid of these stinking oh i grew 100 berries can
i get rid of this stinking these these signs i didn't think
they would stick around it's kind of annoying oops oops oh
ah slam slam slam rancher slam ranchers oh slime rancher
vibes i knocked him over i'm so sorry did i miss any i
wonder if i missed any stars oh oh they're all staring at me
ew the moon ew
okay thanks for playing this me though hope you enjoy as
much as i did the whole consumes all we will have the whole
consume maybe okay i'm gonna save up for the berry the star
wand and then we'll get another berry buddy the game has
lore I figured it did oh my gosh please get out of my way oh
oops no that's not a control
I mean it seems like too like quirky of a game to not have
lore you know what I mean oh oh oh oh oops
oh thank you berry buddy thank you for your berry
contributions oh my goodness there's berries hidden
everywhere i feel like there needs to be a mod of this game
that instead of like what's it called instead of little like
fruit berries they're like berry bug heads you know oh berry
buddy what are you doing you're okay you're okay
Uh, any more?
Please, please, please!
Did I get the money?
No!
But I'll try not to make berry bug jokes the entire time,
and you guys should too.
We're harvesting fruit.
Look at this is my...
This is June.
June's doing her best.
You know?
Are they gonna be all months?
Does it look bigger to you?
No?
You...
Chex?
Oh, Sunny.
Yeah.
We love June.
All right, close.
Just need five.
Yeah, we love June.
Yeah, it does move.
Like, look at it, it's so much smaller now, no?
Oh.
Oh, this is our thing.
Uh, how do I use it?
Oh.
Wait, how do I?
Throw the star wand at Berry Buddies to upgrade them at the
cost of star orbs, okay?
Here you go, June!
Wait, uh...
Oh, it's a raspberry!
Whoa!
June, you turned into a raspberry!
That's crazy!
Oh, oh, I'm not very good at doing this.
Okay, we're sucking.
Oh, I'm too full.
Oh, raspberries, raspberries galore.
All right, the big money is going to start coming in, right?
Whoa!
Yes!
I don't know how much that will...
That will...
A silver coin.
First we had the big portal, now we have the big girl hole.
Oh, okay, good.
Six dollars!
Oh.
Oh, what?
Wait, wait, wait.
It definitely...
No, there was another golden blueberry.
I'm missing them.
We got $32.
Oh, yeah.
Number is going up, everybody.
Number is going up.
And we're going to get another blueberry.
No.
Berry buddy.
And we're going to upgrade them.
How much does it cost?
I guess two?
Come here, heal.
Oh.
No, I don't have enough?
How much?
Zayna!
Oh, I think that's how much.
Oh, I guess.
Now it's six stars.
Oh, okay, okay.
I get it now.
I get it.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Yes.
Suck it up.
Nope.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, that's huge.
Golden.
Oh yeah, the big money's coming in now, guys.
Nice.
Look, we just got cash everywhere.
Oh, go in.
Go in.
I don't know if we're going to make it.
Can I?
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
Oh, nice.
Best Halloween cereal?
I know.
Oh yeah, look, they reject.
It rejects the money.
The whole does not care about such material items.
The whole only cares about feed.
Feeding and growing larger.
And berries, and that's it.
Nothing else.
I think I got all the cash money.
We made...
Wait, $49!
Holy cow!
We made $49!
$100 total.
To remove signs, throw them in the hole.
Oh, wait, that's so good.
Unlock movable hole.
Move the hole.
Will the hole.
Wait, so if I...
Will it what?
Will it suck?
Probably.
Oh, wait.
really suck my vacuum does the hole consumes will it eat
should we try it move in the hole what else can we save up
for vacuum capacity oh fifteen hundred dollars okay we
should think within our means right five hundred dollars
unlock auto pickup nearby coins that's not bad 250 we can
increase the day length sledgehammer blitz ability
significantly increases growth rate for a short duration
okay 50 000 50 000 6 2 000 5 million okay let's move the
hole i guess oh whole movement speed very buddy hundred
dollars whole movement range we've completed 10 days remy
welcome to membership thank you Okay, wait, so you into the
hole?
I can't get it in.
How do I make it?
How do I move it, though?
Aim and press Q to set a destination.
Oh my god, it ate!
Oh, and it made a star!
Double tap Q to start.
Wait, take it.
Oh, nope, that's not what I meant to do.
Wait, um, how do I do it?
Q, Q, Q?
Q?
Double tap Q to stop the whole... It doesn't move anymore.
Oh gosh, he almost died.
Oh, let's gather some things.
I'm just trying to... Oh, the more I feed it, the more it
moves.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Okay, that was fine.
That day was... Today was figuring out how to do everything.
That's fine.
That's okay.
I missed some more stars, though.
I'll have to get them.
Yeah, it needs fuel to move.
Okay.
I think we got it now, though.
I think we understand.
Yeah, we're learning the new tech.
Oh, yeah.
Hello.
Oh, oh.
Let's, uh, let's upgrade.
Um, you.
Yeah.
Yay!
Okay, now we're all raspberries.
Uh, Q?
Oh, come on.
It's so close.
Oh, eat.
Are you stuck?
What are you doing?
Whoa!
Oh, my gosh.
The whole will groweth.
The whole...
Oh, my god, he's stuck for real.
Get out of there.
Oh, okay, so then I can, like, Q.
and eat the next rock.
Okay, wait, I need more berries.
Please, please, please, please.
Let me make it.
The whole grow is larger!
So, it seems our coins and stuff disappear, but the stars
come back at least, which is nice.
Alright.
I want to save up for that.
Automatically pick up coins.
I think...
Okay, then we should be able to throw these signs into the
hole now.
Oh, there's more money over here.
We gotta really be careful.
The coins fling everywhere.
What happens when the hole becomes too big for a little
area?
Well, what happens?
Knowing how to control your hole is a very important life
skill after all.
I agree.
All right, here we go.
Throw it in.
Oh, okay.
We'll figure it out.
What are you guys doing over here?
Oh, oh sorry.
Who are you?
Oh.
June, you're doing an amazing job.
You're doing an amazing job.
Don't let anyone tell you otherwise.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, golden, golden, golden.
Yes, good job, good job.
We're sucking and we're, we're making money.
Be careful!
Be careful now!
Don't go in there!
Come on!
It's so close.
So close to eating that.
Oh wait!
Q?
Ah!
I missed out.
That's fine.
Holy cow!
Look at all this money!
We're rich.
We're rich and... Okay, don't consume me hold i know you're
hungry but i'm not a bear i'm a ghost i okay we'll get rid
of the signs tomorrow too we are so rich unlocks the
sledgehammer i don't want to do i want to save up the 500.
i'm hungry watching this is the number one raspberry lover
okay you have a competition though with me i think i'm the
number one raspberry lover
oh nice
um oh no our sad guy can i take you yeah and we'll also grab
the star wherever it went oh here we go Yes,
give me, yes, yes, oh, oh, don't try to die, Zena, Zena.
All ready?
I didn't, I didn't get to consume anything today.
Oh, ah, dang.
like any rocks and stuff the hole will I think the hole will
eat us
why the music slap though it's so fun oh I missed I missed a
couple right now I know it's going to get to the point where
we're going to make so much money that little coins like
that don't matter so much but right now every coin counts
right now we need every single coin maybe i should get the
sledgehammer i don't know the whole hungers i love
raspberries i'll keep saving up just a little bit 500 is a
lot to wait you know so maybe we can invest in something
that will give us more money like another I almost said boo
buddy again.
Like another berry buddy.
Get consumed by hole equals less money.
Sledgehammer, what does it do?
Good for smash and stuff.
The whole movement range we might need as well.
But it doesn't need to go super far right now, I guess.
Hammer probably breaks the stars.
Maybe?
Let's get it.
Let's find out.
Yeah, only one way.
For now?
Oh, please use responsibly do not throw.
Oh, dang it.
That's not what I meant.
Uh, throw?
What if I throw it?
That's not- Okay, I thought it was gonna- That's not what I
expected.
Oh even if the hole gets bigger!
It doesn't matter!
Oh, consume 10 props!
Oh!
Oh yeah.
QQQQQQ Oh, I don't think I'm gonna make it though.
QQ!
Ah, dang it.
I need more props.
I need to eat more props.
Consume, consume, become bigger.
And then, get more money.
Throw in Barry, get more money.
So now we learned what our sledgehammer is for.
Wait, what's going on out here?
It's so creepy.
Whoa!
Gosh, thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the fifth egg after!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much!
The true Minto show.
I know I said I was going to save up, but...
More buddies means more money, honey.
Okay, we won't worry about going outside just yet.
We need to worry about everything else first.
Right?
Oh, oh, oh, nice, nice, nice.
Maybe I shouldn't have bro- What the heck?
So many stars!
Wait.
Ah!
Oh, it's- wait.
Is it because I- A-soft?
Maybe?
Oh, nice.
Huge, huge, huge.
We can- yeah, we can get another berry, buddy, up to...
Up to raspberry as well.
Ew.
Whoa!
So many stars.
Oh my gosh.
Please don't eat me.
I am but a ghost mid.
The rock is gone.
So then what we could do is break down these walls and have
him start.
Well, he should...
The Hulk should consume this stuff first.
right?
I mean, I guess it doesn't really matter, but $83.
So we eat more props.
Oh, oh!
Excuse me!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Now we can upgrade these guys.
I want to see what happens after Raspberry.
You.
You are now a strawberry, Zena!
You're so cute!
Look at you!
I wish I could... I wish it were easier to grab these!
Alright.
Yes.
I... What is all this for, I wonder?
Why... Why do we...
Uh-oh.
You hear all that?
You hear all that cash?
Oh, the money falling scared me.
I was like, there's, I don't think there's monsters or
anything in this game besides the hole.
And me.
I'm, you know, destroying this place, but.
Okay, tomorrow we suck up these guys.
$60 today.
Could have been better.
Could have been better, team.
We'll get them next time.
Strawberries out here.
There's strawberries here.
A little strawberry, guys.
This set is so cute.
Yeah, we'll get them tomorrow.
Yeah, we'll eat the gnomes.
Happy 22 months, Bidou.
Thank you so much.
Happy 22 months.
Okay.
All right, let's start consuming.
All right.
Good job, team.
Oh, strawberry, huge.
Oh, gold, gold, strawberry.
Money like we've never seen before.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Consume a gnome.
I got an achievement for it.
Uh-oh.
Am I the baddie?
Consuming gnomes and...
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Can you go there?
Okay, let's start upgrading our guys to Raspberry.
June, you are now a strawberry.
How much for you?
Oh, how much to upgrade you?
Oh, wait!
Yes, I got it in time.
I got it in time.
The golden strawberry.
There's other... I missed a lot It kind of have to like
focus on one thing or the other, right?
Maybe the hole can't tell the difference between berries and
berry cute ghosts.
That could be the case, but that means the hole is stupid.
No, I'm just kidding.
I love the hole.
It's giving me money.
Oh, we're here already dying.
Thank you, Retro!
Thank you.
What can we buy?
Berry Blitz.
Day length.
I think a day length is pretty good.
10 extra seconds.
It's a minute long.
That's all you get.
Let's get more time in the day.
80 seconds.
Chainsaw!
Lend up berries to make smoothies and break walls faster.
I got a chainsaw!
I'll make smoothies.
If my dad keeps going this way, I just might eat some
berries tonight.
Let's save.
Thank you.
Alright, I really want the auto pickup though.
We need cash money.
Already on day 19.
I guess the days happen very...
Oh, my stars!
Yeah.
oh no no that's oh good good good and then heal and then we
can upgrade um where are you where's where where did he go
okay never mind i give up
where did he i guess he escaped probably he probably escaped
Eat him.
Oh!
Thank you.
Ah, I was so close.
Wow, look at all the money we've got, guys.
I need the auto pickup so bad.
I need the auto pickup like yesterday.
Big money.
So much money.
Blue Hawaiian.
does it eat it while it's like trying to get me i can't
really tell does it eat the money do i lose money we made
178 dollars oh he's fast okay wait put put put there's some
more here oh okay okay okay chill chill chill we're chill
we're chill i'm going to bed oh it spits it out okay
for the auto pickup for real now we can actually do it if we
make if we make almost 200 in a day we'll make it easy peasy
all right we'll set it to you oh i made them both i made you
a raspberry that's why i couldn't find you that's why all
right uh where are you raspberry where do you go where do
you go oh there you are Is this name Elbow?
Wait.
Golden Raspberry.
One last final treat.
Thank you.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that, but that's okay.
We can see if he could go all the way over here.
It'd be crazy.
No, like right here.
Oh, close.
Oh!
More stars!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my stars.
Oh my stars, oh my stars!
How much do you need?
Okay, a lot.
Never mind.
Oh, dang it.
I'm gonna stood up.
Ah.
Okay.
Alright, good job team.
Good job team.
You could do it for sure.
Yeah?
Oh, Becca.
It's so hard because I feel like I can't read...
I thought this game would be a little more like I could read
chat and do this, but...
It's so, the days are so short and it's so chaotic and I, I,
everything is happening all at once.
I'm like, what the hell is going on?
Getting more stars will be your biggest benefit.
I think so too.
I wish I could break them after night.
But of course we want more money too.
But yeah, oh no, no, no!
I dropped $78 down the hole.
No!
I'm gonna move you guys over just a tad.
All right, go like that.
Dang it.
No!
Sorry for my scream.
Ah, we lost so much money.
I would have been...
I would have been over halfway.
Green star!
Now what the heck is that?
What could that be?
Good job team.
Oh, green star.
Whoa!
Alright.
Are you June?
Who are you?
Elbow!
Elbow's a kiwi!
One second.
I'll read it.
Super Chat censoring a very cute no way.
Why is censor- Oh, sorry Elbow.
Um, can I get you over here?
it doesn't have a good rain okay that's what it means though
by like range of oh damn it I forgot that's okay that's okay
we won't fall today probably why does it why does a YouTube
sensor very cute
no no is that a oh it's just a blueberry though but it's a
golden golden kiwi He's gonna go crazy whenever we get him.
Oh, my money.
We'll go outside eventually.
I'm too scared right now.
Okay, okay, oh, tomorrow we'll be able to buy the auto
pickup.
Oh, I've got an achievement for making $1,000.
Might need to open the wall so buddies don't get lost behind
them.
Yeah, one time.
A digital donut that is exclusively for the very cutest
ghost made in the biz.
Thank you.
Cute, cute still works.
Auto pickup being $500 feels kind of rude.
I know, right?
It's okay though.
This is, it's a, it's a, it's a, you know, this is an honest
job.
All right, let's try and get these things.
We'll get more stars.
And I don't think I can upgrade any.
have you?
No.
Not yet.
Alright, I'm gonna need you not to be over there.
Can you be a little closer to the hole, please?
Alright, team.
What are we doing?
We're producing berries.
Yes, indeed.
Yes, we are.
And we're gonna suck up all this stuff.
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Why is it so difficult grabbing these?
At least they don't disappear.
That's one thing I am grateful for.
Alright, tomorrow will probably be our day of breaking down
the walls.
Ah, no way!
That was so rude.
Oh, okay.
Let's break down these walls!
reading so many messages today.
Wait, really?
Why?
What's going on?
You too?
It's not me.
Why would Barry cute even be censored?
It's crazy.
A coin in my bed!
For the tooth fairy!
It's so dark.
Auto pick up.
Oh, I feel so good.
Let's extend the range as well.
Because then I think we can get more stuff.
The AI overlords are mad.
You're not saying AI is cute enough.
They're jealous.
Jealousy is ugly.
Okay.
They're like, no, I'm so cute, please.
Whoa, whoa.
Okay, time to smash.
A whole world is out here.
Oh.
Or a wall.
I like how I got auto pickup and I'm not even like, wow.
Oh, oops.
What's this?
Whoa, whoa.
All right.
Oh.
Good job, good job.
I really wish I could break the um, the stars at night
because I feel like I'm doing everything but doing that, you
know?
Look, I'm picking it up.
Easy peasy.
Yes.
Oh, it feels so good.
I'm not having to click on every single individual one.
I can't even pick that up.
I can't even smash the walls at night.
Oh.
Alright.
YouTube took my fingies.
They're that hungry.
What is this?
Oh, it's a star.
I was driving since I started the stream and trying to
figure out what this game is.
From the sounds alone felt insane.
Yeah, I feel a little insane right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel...
I feel silly.
I'm like, yes, berries.
Yes, consume.
Yes, the whole.
Smash!
Wow!
Oh, whoa.
Already a golden?
Gonna be gonna be golden.
Wait, um, can I upgrade anybody?
You?
Oh, you need 12.
Where's our other buddy?
Another one?
Good job, elbow.
Elbows.
Elbows really putting in the weight right now.
Everybody else should learn elbow as an example.
Okay.
I want to go into that room for sure.
It's just, I can't stop collecting the berries.
Let's go over here and get those.
When will my hole grow?
Whop, whop.
I don't know if we'll have...
Please, please, please, please, please.
Nice.
No!
We'll eat them tomorrow, for sure.
You can go in the room at night.
Oh, you're right.
Enter the password.
And stuff is censored.
Whoa, holy cow.
Whoa.
So many.
Edo items.
Meat warp.
If you want a really chill, idle, incremental game, the app
over, I highly recommend.
Nodebuster.
I'll look into it.
Thank you.
Very Blitz again.
No, I don't know what to get next.
Hmm.
Golden Berry Chance.
It's only 2%?
I feel like we have gotten so many.
Vacuum capacity might be good.
Popgun.
Shoot darts that break star orbs!
What will make me more money?
The movement range?
There is the Barry Blitz.
We could try it.
Barry Blitz is good to have.
Dims, welcome back.
Let's try it.
We're gonna Barry Blitz immediately.
Oh.
Uh.
Press G to activate Barry Blitz.
Oh.
Uh, can I...
There we go.
Dang it, I thought I would get that one.
Alright, here we go.
Oh!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Uh.
Okay, we can't do another one for 10 minutes, though.
Dang.
All right.
So many bearers.
I should have a vacuum.
The hall grows larger!
My hole.
Bigger, bigger, bigger, bigger, bigger, bigger, bigger,
bigger.
Yes.
So much money.
Oh, dang it.
Okay, I need to break down these walls, I think.
I think so.
I think it's time.
Yay!
A thousand dollars!
The hole is larger, the hole is larger.
I could get another berry body.
Whole movement range from 50 to 100.
Let me sleep on it.
Or rather, go through the day on it.
I have some stuff I need to do first, right?
Break this.
Can I have my sledgehammer?
Thank you.
Break that.
Oh.
Break, break, break, break that!
Break that!
Alright, good job?
Oh my gosh, they're working and like...
Oh, I missed one.
I missed a wall.
Oh, these are like weird stars.
Oh, okay.
Can I get you to go here?
Thank you.
Oh, oh, I got it, I got it.
Can I get you to go here?
Are you stuck?
I got you.
No berries are stuck on my watch.
Break the weird stars, can I?
I have to, I think I have to suck them up.
But let's break stars anyway.
Because I need to.
They're all like all over the place.
I didn't make so much money today, but that's alright.
You win some, you lose some.
on something else.
Cool!
Did I get out my money?
Money, money, money, money.
What could the password be?
Oh!
We could make the day longer.
Popka.
Nice try, nice try, thank you.
More berry blitz.
Berry fountain ability.
It significantly increases the whole size and launches all
berries towards it.
What?
That's crazy!
Your check-in postcards just came in the mail.
Let's go!
Four letter word, mint.
Must be.
Let's get a new berry buddy.
Yes, yes!
Eat this.
Eat that.
Oh, let's break these.
If I could grab them.
Oh, yeah.
I got you.
This way.
Okay, I think I've broken all of them now, so...
Peep up, peep up, peep up, peep up, peep up, peep up, peep
up, peep up, peep up, peep up, I would also like to get my
vacuum capacity up as well.
So maybe...
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Maybe we can save up for that.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
No.
Oh, so many.
Holy cow.
Um.
you oh no no no no
we must destroy the fence okay wait we have so much going on
in here first of all we gotta we gotta aim we gotta stay
within our with our little constraints first every penny
counts truly every penny counts how does the money get all
the way over here anyway, though.
Whoa!
Alright, let's upgrade.
How much to elbow?
Elbow, how much do you cost?
25!
We could do that.
Elbow.
You're gonna be...
Oops.
I threw it the wrong way.
Wait, I threw it.
Like, how tall is the ceiling?
Whoa, wait a second.
Meat mop.
Oh, here, here, here.
Alright.
I'm guessing the blitz is in real time, then.
Still says six minutes, right?
Elbow?
What are you doing over here, Elbow?
I need you!
Oh, that's the sledgehammer, sorry.
I look like I'm about to murder him.
There's the star.
Elbow!
Come here.
No!
Elbow!
Elbow, I have terrible aim.
Elbow, I really need you.
You're a plumb!
You're a plumb, Elbow!
You're so cute!
I love Elbow.
Alright, we sleep.
And let's do the range up too.
him elbow elbow elbow elbow elbow elbow i should probably
have gotten that um holy wait we should probably upgrade the
other guys too if i can oh i need that gun i need the gun
that allows you to shoot um the things oh what is this wait
Wait, wait.
Wait, what is this?
It's like a puzzle.
It's not something to suck up.
Okay, I'll go this way instead.
Meatball, meatball, meatball, meatball.
Yes, very good.
Oh.
Very interesting.
Ooh, golden.
Nice.
I'm so bad at getting the stars.
Don't eat me, please.
Yeah, I guess it's tic-tac-toe or something.
It's creepy.
Ugly.
Yes.
I didn't make so much money.
I'm not making so much money.
Very interesting, yes.
Uh, let's get these guys over here maybe.
Oh, what's this?
To whom it may concern.
Oh, lore.
How do you start one of these?
My name is Donna Bellinger, and I know what happened to
Barry Pomeroy.
I found my first cassette tape.
Who's a Barry Pomeroy?
Oh my gosh.
Imagine trying to collect the berries at the same time as
like all the money.
Oh, he consumed 10 gnomes!
Meat, meat, meat, meat.
Ah, dang, I was so close.
The auto-collect is like imperative.
You must have it.
I wish I could tell what is a coin though.
It's kind of difficult.
Lure!
Are there any other?
Um.
Cassette tapes then?
Interesting.
Is Barry in the hole?
Oh my god.
I need to break these.
I have a problem.
I have a star infestation.
Beep, pop, pop, pop.
Oops.
Let's, like, get you over there.
Okay.
Today we'll be upgrading our guys.
So, you.
Oh, no.
No.
And you.
Yeah!
June, good job.
Let's suck up those gnomes.
Alright.
Getting stars.
And...
Well, we won't worry about cash money right now.
Just get in the stars so we can upgrade our guys.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Right here is good.
Oh.
Uh, will I make it?
I don't know if I will.
Oh.
No, we missed a golden one.
That's okay, though.
Oh, please.
Yes.
Good.
Don't worry so much about cash today.
We got 20, we got back to, we were at, we got back to the
26, oh, thank you.
26 stars, so that's good.
Nice.
Vacuum capacity, okay, I'm gonna save up for that.
Nice, too.
Yeah.
Holy, guys, I think I'm in trouble!
I have too many stars!
I mean it's a great thing!
But also...
I can't keep up with all of them!
Meepop!
I can't keep- Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I can't keep up with all these stars and yet I keep
collecting more.
But it's imperative.
Goodbye, gnome.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that gnome's life was worth so many stars.
Alright.
Can I upgrade anybody before we...
Before we end the day?
You.
Oh, come on.
Yeah!
There's just fruit everywhere.
Everything is a mess.
Yes.
Got all my money, all my cash.
I didn't make so much today either.
But I think we have enough for the upgrade for the back
kill.
Yes.
Yippee!
I know everything's a mess.
Everything is a mess.
Everything is crazy.
This game is crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I'm
just trying to break them apart for now.
Oh, we can almost do another Barry Blitz!
Let's go.
We'll send the hole back over here again.
Go, my hole.
Go!
Ooh, golden.
Oh my god, oh my god, so many more.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm pressing D, but it doesn't work.
Can I upgrade anybody?
Who would like to be upgraded?
You.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
My aim is so dooky.
Yeah.
I don't think we'll make it.
No!
I didn't think I would.
It's okay.
Okay, I think that's all that I'm on my knee.
Oh, I missed another golden.
It's okay, it's just a blueberry.
This...
There's so much stuff to take care of.
There's so much stuff to take care of!
I have my buddies.
I have my berries.
I have so much going on.
Let's just send the hole that way.
Yeah.
Oh my guys like are disappearing.
Don't even know where they are.
We have 40 stars again.
Look at you.
Upsy.
Oh, your name is Upsy.
That's so cute.
The blitz is ready.
I think maybe I have an idea of how to do the blitz.
If we...
If we bring it over here, because it all comes out of the,
uh, out of that guy.
If we get our, um, our hole over by it, then we could do the
blitz and have it all just go straight into the hole.
You know?
You feel in the vision?
I also want to try this.
Blitz ready, baby.
ready for the blitz i'm ready for big cash money let's do it
yeah i just have to make sure i get it in the right spot
right so maybe like right here
okay maybe this is close enough at least okay here we go
blitz
Okay, a little closer, a little closer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Does it seem like we made a good amount of money, maybe?
It worked, I think.
I think it worked, maybe.
Oh my gosh, so much.
Oh, no!
There were several golden kiwis!
No!
No, the body!
No, the- look how many berries there are everywhere!
What the heck?
The body!
Alright.
Berry blisteration.
Fountain ability.
I'm gonna sleep on it.
The FOMO.
Not the FOMO fear.
I did miss out.
This is ridiculous.
Alright, who's a guy that we can upgrade?
You?
Yeah!
Oh, is that June?
Oh, no, that's not what I meant to do.
Let's get that rock right there.
Consume.
And let's get these flamingos.
Yes.
Oh my god, there's so many here too.
No, no, no, no!
I'm sucking, I'm sucking!
No, I'm sucking!
Suck!
No!
Oh, I didn't get that many as much as I thought.
Okay.
Today was a little bit of a bust.
That's okay.
You win some and you lose some.
This game feels tough to optimize, you know?
This guy right here, mysterious star.
I have to do it.
Maybe...
Hmm.
Maybe I have to bust down the walls to get them.
Or something.
Auto.
coin pickup range no no i think i'm okay for right now we'll
get it later i think i will do the day length though for now
i like how chaotic it is it's fun to watch the numbers go up
but also so so much happening
oh my tiny brain is going kind of insane Saino style right
now.
Oh.
Sooner.
Actually, tomorrow we'll aim for this area too.
It'll be super crazy.
We'll get so much.
We'll get so many stars.
I don't even know what to do with them.
Yes.
Yes!
Oh, little gnome here.
Where even is the sun?
Oh, there he is.
I don't know, can I grab him?
Oh, I can't.
I thought I'd be able to grab the gnome.
His little life is worth so many stars.
You're a star, gnome, you're a star.
Actually, you're like five stars.
Want to hint on how to manage stars?
Sure.
Sure, yeah.
How do I manage the stars?
Without the gun.
Because I don't have the gun.
Berry Blitz bonus growth.
What does that mean?
Whole movement.
Berry Buddy is now $10,000.
Movement spin.
Oh, I want the flower to bush.
I grow three berries.
We can upgrade our kiwi to a plum.
Actually, let's upgrade elbow if I can.
Now, 50k is a lot.
Elbow?
Julin.
Upsi.
Elbow!
50!
50, okay.
Yikes.
Oh, my gosh.
I might have enough.
Who knows?
Sometimes I grab it and it doesn't throw it.
Come get this guy right here.
Oh wait!
No no no!
I messed up!
Over here, over here, over here.
I forgot what our plan was.
I forgot.
I was like, oh yeah, we're gonna grab these things.
In Twanto.
I think we could do it, maybe.
More plums, please.
More plums.
Alright, I need all plums on deck.
Here it comes!
Oh no!
Oh!
Oops, all stars!
Alright, we can grab the rest of it.
What's this?
Oh, the rest of it tomorrow, maybe.
Awesome.
Yes.
Wow, we got 4,000.
What is this?
Oh, I don't go in.
Can destroy harder walls.
Okay, so I don't even think my sledgehammer can take down
the...
The fence then, right?
probably.
We'll just wake up.
Nice soon.
Good
job, team.
I'll start sucking and let's get that guy over here.
All right, let's consume those parts.
Oh yeah.
Consume those parts.
Oh wait, now I can upgrade.
Um, elbow?
Elbow?
Jun.
Upsi.
Elbow?
Elbow!
Elbow, I need you!
Elbow will always lead the charge!
Wait, which one's Elbow?
Elbow?
Are you... Elbow.
Elbow, you're...
What are you?
Wait, what are you?
Elbow!
What are you?
What is he?
An apple?
Maybe?
Ah, just a little bit more.
June was the OG.
Elbow is just an usurper.
No, Elbow is so great!
Elbow's always been a great help!
I love Elbow.
It doesn't matter who was here first.
I love all my berries equally.
Mostly.
Elbow's just really great.
It's a great personality.
Bank, $10,000 total.
June was your most loyal companion and you dropped her for a
guy with a silly name.
Why are you guys getting so...
You are not better than me.
Don't act like it.
Don't act like you're better than me.
Can I even bury Blitz?
I don't think I can.
What's the fountain?
Let's try it.
Well, fountain!
Right before the day is over.
Oh, H to activate the fountain.
Okay, eat mop.
Okay, I want to upgrade our Kiwi guy.
I don't remember who it is.
Oh my god, I think it's Upsi.
No, actually, I think Upsi is.
Who are you?
Zena!
Oh my god, Zana.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I can't get you yet.
Just kidding.
Hold on.
Let me make some more money.
Or not money.
Let me get some more stars.
This way, this way, this way.
How much?
I wish I could suck the stars.
No, no!
Okay, good.
It still worked.
Alright, let's see now if we can do it.
Zena!
Oh, Zena?
Oh, go.
What?
How much are you worth?
25!
Oh my gosh, I just needed one more.
Oops.
Oh, fountain!
I found it!
I found it got way!
Wasted.
No.
Fountain cooldown.
10 minutes.
Bro moment.
I know.
Oh my god.
Good job team.
Alright.
Zena.
Where are you?
Oh, don't move.
Alright.
Let's keep putting the hole over there.
Keep getting that hole over there.
Good job, everyone.
Team effort.
Why did you all...
I said I would do it at the end.
end and then i did and whoops oh there was just a little
less time than i thought there would be oh they gave hate to
me good job good job
it's okay we'll do it again eventually or something they'll
both be they'll both be um they'll both cool down at the
same time No, no, no, no!
Run, run, run.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, we got some more pots this time.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh yeah.
We got some more pots this time.
Okay.
We're getting there, guys.
Look, our place is pretty clean, though, no?
So far, it's getting there.
It's getting cleaner.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Let's fight, we'll see.
Day 42!
Alright, hold.
You know where to go.
Put you in the corner.
Nobody puts a baby in the corner, except me.
Put the whole baby in the corner.
Ha!
Yeah.
I'm baby.
You are baby!
Little baby, little baby.
Are these all my stars?
No way.
Oh, that was close.
He looks so sad.
Why are you so sad?
What are you doing in here?
This is my office.
It's like going into your parents' room and you're just
like, you're not allowed in here.
Oh, yeah!
Baby!
We do have the blitz ready, but I'll wait until...
Well, I'll wait until we can fountain with it, because I
think that would be...
Because so much... so many berries accumulate all over.
I think it would just be better to combine them.
Maybe.
I would like to try it at least.
It's only seven minutes?
It's like... that's like a week from now.
In-game.
A weak in-game.
In these types of games, the growth will always be slow in
the start, but soon.
Soon we will reach max.
Oh my god, I didn't even realize it still had so many stars.
I think I...
I think I almost just fell in.
I think it was because I sucked up a lot of pots.
soon be be where is elbow anyway is that guy working is that
guy doing his job yes he is good job elbow nice save thank
you i know he almost spell it for real so bad
golden apple elbow you you see elbows the goat soon you guys
will realize how valuable elbow is to our team.
Pick up five coins by hand after purchasing...
Oh, I didn't mean to.
I got an achievement for accidentally picking up coins.
I like the Mario tool we got going on.
I don't think we'll...
I think we should get stars while I...
Oh.
One single star.
Alright.
June?
June is great.
June is, June's doing their best.
Everybody's awesome.
Hot dog.
I heard something.
It sounded like an alarm or like a bang, bang, bang.
Like, it sounded like a, like a old clock going off, you
know?
Hot dog, thank you!
Is this a golden?
No, golden apple.
Are you still afraid of slime rancher?
This is basically that, but no cute slime's jumping at you.
Really?
Maybe I could handle it then.
Maybe I could handle it.
Almost a 10,000.
10,000 will open up a lot of options for us, so...
June my Oshi.
Everybody's rooting for the underdogs.
You guys just love an underdog.
That's why.
No!
I...
I hit.
No!
What is...
golden something oh wait uh let's do the rest of the stuff
in this corner look he produced another elbow is awesome he
produced another golden apple apples are our highest hey
wait did i shoot it where did it go i oh my god i
accidentally released it holy cow
i can't help that the elbow just has such a great work ethic
like okay like everybody else needs to pull their weight
that's just the reality of it elbow is leading the charge
i don't see any golden gray or plums i keep thinking they're
grapes their plums are but don't they don't they look like
they look like grapes so much this game makes me want fruit
oh my god our guy is all the way over here I'm so sorry hi
Minto hello hello we're making now $2,000 a day at least
awesome we're killing it you guys we're killing it and we're
killing gnomes vacuum capacity the pop gun i think i need
the pop gun berry buddy
it's rooting tooting shooting time where's my gun
i'll get it i'll get it i'm hitting the gnome All right.
Elbow is now 100.
Oops.
Why is my throw is way too powerful?
Oh, I'm popping.
Yeah.
All right, we're going to get the rest of the things in this
corner.
Like, yeah.
Just keep on coming.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sometimes I walk by the fruit and I feel like I'm picking
them up.
Like it's just...
But I'm not.
I know.
Like kind of like how I auto pick up the...
The uh...
The money.
I feel like I'm auto picking up fruit.
Oh there's pop darts everywhere!
Now I'm making a mess.
Uh oh.
Will we make it?
I don't know if we will!
Please!
Just a little bit more!
Ah!
So close.
That was a lot of stars we got, though.
The popcorn is awesome.
Do not cry.
For we are doing amazing.
And you are amazing.
Okay, fountain soon!
Fountain soon!
Oh!
joke.
Hold on,
hold on, hold on.
Alright, team.
I think the next thing we should aim for is another boo
buddy.
Very buddy.
My bad.
You know what?
No.
This is my game.
This is my stream.
I could call them.
I could call them boo buddies.
They're boo buddies, probably.
They're my little boo buddies.
Doesn't matter if they're berries.
Or buddies.
Or How many times can I say Barry buddy?
Okay.
I gotta go fast.
Gotta go fast.
Come on, come on, come on.
I don't want to get sucked up, though.
Come on, come on.
I don't want to get sucked up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Come on, team.
I gotta upgrade some more people, though.
No!
Oh, shoot.
Please, please.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please!
The whole grow is larger!
Watch it get grown in real time.
That was terrifying.
Wait, all my cash is over here, so don't eat me, please.
Okay, thank you.
The whole groweth.
Okay, maybe this area is kind of tough to get the stuff to
still for me.
Maybe.
Okay, we're saving up for another boo buddy.
Boo berry buddy.
A berry berry, berry boo buddy.
Oh, wow.
Maybe we could do it.
It's just the two items.
Come on, team.
Let's get growing!
Grow, grow, grow, grow, grow, grow, grow.
Grow all you got.
Oh, don't fall in the hole.
Yay!
Yeah, good job, Upsi!
Alright, let's upgrade some guys, right?
Oh, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, that's not what I meant to
do.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope.
Um, who are you?
Upsi!
Good job, Upsi!
You've been promoted!
For some reason, I like can't, my brain can't comprehend
that they're apples and that they're like worth more than
the other things that we've been growing.
I don't know what it is about like the apple just seems like
a basic fruit, no?
Come on, oh, come on.
Oh my god, you've been holding out on me.
You've been putting all these plums in my office.
Come on, go, go.
No!
I'm never gonna get this damn lawnmower.
By volume, apples are super cheap.
I know!
So like my brain is just like, oh yeah, apples, the red ones
are not as lucrative.
I'm never gonna get this lot more.
They were really holding out on us!
Is there three in there?
There's three!
There's three plums in there!
I'm sorry to say it was June hiding plums in the office.
fired see why won't you guys understand i have i i know i
know my dear employees is maybe she feels neglected maybe
it's my fault june we'll upgrade you wait i need more stars
actually okay wait uh maybe i should try over here first i
keep trying to get like the clear out that corner but now
we're not making any more stars because of it so okay we'll
we'll go for today but tomorrow we'll get this area it will
be much easier i believe than another golden apple the blitz
oh my gosh it's blitz in time okay blitz blitz blitz
The hole grows larger!
We got them!
We got- Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, it was a huge success!
It was a huge success!
I mean, I only got a couple stars from it, but that's still
great!
The cash we got!
Do you guys hear it?
There's like something behind there that's making noise.
Big money.
Thank you guys for telling me about this.
the blitzes.
Alright.
Alright, tomorrow we get that.
So many things.
We could upgrade our sledgehammer, but I would like to clear
out more of this area before we do that.
Berry buddy.
I need more stars though, for sure.
In this corner.
In this corner!
Oh my god.
I'm just shooting.
I'm just shooting anywhere.
My aim.
There's like a crazy drop off on this thing.
Yes.
Everything will be consumed.
The numbers will go high.
Okay, let's...
Like right here.
We'll get whatever's there.
Yes, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good,
good, good, good, good.
Hello?
There we go.
Hello.
More stars.
Dang, we went from 15 stars to 15.
That's how much we got just from doing that area.
That's awesome.
Oh man, I'm actually moving him!
That's so funny.
Can I shoot you?
No reaction.
Imagine if he came down.
I was just like, are you trying to shoot me?
So much money.
Oh wait, there's like money on top of the puzzle.
I don't think I can get, I gotta lead the hole over here.
What's the new buddy's name?
Oh, that's a great question.
Oh, I have to find out.
Tomorrow!
Whole movement speed.
Wait, that would be really good.
Whole movement range.
I don't know which... I feel like...
Speed maybe.
We want...
I can't believe it's already almost been two hours of this
game.
I think I'm obsessed.
I'd go speed first.
Yeah, I think so too.
We only have $41.
I'm broke.
Snizzle!
Uh-oh.
I'm a really big fan of you, Snizzle.
Snizzle, Snizzle.
Who are you?
Elbow.
Elbow, get out of the corner.
You better work or...
Snizzle might come for your job.
Oh, look how fast it is now!
Snizzles produce a lot of fruit.
Alright, let's go over here now.
Like, over here.
Oh, oops.
No, no!
I didn't mean to do that.
I need more apples.
Need more apples.
I'm my most lucrative fruit right now.
Alright, 85.
I would like...
Because it seems like once you...
Once you upgrade the fruit...
Like a fruit.
The bush will start, like, producing that, you know?
So I think it's good to...
Let me just throw it in.
Darts.
I'm thinking I'm throwing in fruit.
though to uh at least have one guy so then the bush will
start producing the new fruit you know what i mean that's
what i think replace june with snizzle i'm not gonna replace
june i just need her to work a little harder
can afford berry buddy upgrade Yeah baby.
Let's get you all going into the corner over here.
Who are you?
June!
You made a golden!
June's comeback arc!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah!
Let's start going down over here now.
Oh, hello.
Me, ma, oh, oh.
Nice.
Where are you?
Wait.
Elbow?
Uh, who are you?
Elbow!
You're a pair!
Oh my god, he's a pair!
So cute.
Producing pairs already.
He's like, yeah.
I'll accept this job.
I accept the task.
Can we get the gnome?
This game is way more chaotic than I thought it was gonna
be.
But it's also so addictive.
I like I've mentioned before but I really like monotonous
games like this where it's just like you do the thing and
the thing happens and you do more.
and thing grows and get more money and then do thing and
then you get more and then it's so awesome it's just
addicting you know
i probably should have upgraded my blueberry snizzle we
probably should have upgraded him menial tasks incrementals
weird lore it's very you i live to be to do menial tasks
even though i'm not even living I crave the menial tasks.
I crave them.
I think
we got that gnome.
Oh, nope.
I can't shoot yet.
Don't fall in, Zina.
Don't fall in.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh,
no.
Please.
Please, hold.
You can get it, you can get it.
Oh, there's so many stars.
We're clearing out this whole room.
Holy cow.
Can I eat it?
Oh my god!
Get the gnome family.
There's a single flamingo.
Who's in here?
Oh my god!
This is just craziness.
Dang it.
Um, how am I supposed to get my money?
Okay, this is kind of...
This is a little...
Ooh, oof, oof.
Okay, I think I got it all.
Oh!
On Friday, April 12th, we had a short shooting day, and the
rest of the crew was leaving early.
Barry reached out to me via email that morning talk about
things he knew that I already knew what the meeting was
about he wanted to have a face-to-face so I began planning
so ominous I think I just saw something fall in there.
Hmm.
We only have 21 stars.
I'll save up for.
We can do more berry blitz duration.
That would be good.
And the growth?
Yeah, we'll get those.
We'll just grab them for now.
More money.
And we'll get a berry blitz soon-ish, so let's cool all
right all the way over here hole oh my god oh my god i was
like dang i don't have very many stars but um i just haven't
collected them holy cow holy cow
i should have i should get them while they like come out of
the hole you know you're a star you're a star What's that
one Mia Goth movie where she goes, I'm a star.
Um.
What is it?
Excuse me.
Somebody once told me!
Guys, I think that is everything besides this one flamingo.
I think we've gotten everything in this area.
I think we've cleared out the area entirely.
I don't know if I'll make this.
Nope.
I didn't think so.
I'm gonna need you to move, though.
Yeah.
We'll get all this stuff from over here.
Was there anything from over here?
No.
Oh, all my coins are flying around.
They don't know where to go.
We just gotta lead it over here some, a little bit.
Time to break some walls yeah it's top wait i have to
upgrade my sledgehammer first i think actually i think
that's a 10 000 upgrade so we really need to focus on cash
money now no no come over here please so i will upgrade uh
especially oh especially blueberry buddy
okay good all right all right Is it this one?
Yeah.
So we need the, we need the 3000.
There is still the puzzle on the PC.
I didn't see any numbers or anything though.
Grab, grab this guy.
Oh, I forgot about all the stars.
No, I forgot about them.
All right.
It's okay.
I'll get them next time.
I don't want to waste my time with shooting at them.
I want to waste my time with collecting money.
Making money, baby.
Oh, I didn't even realize we got a golden one.
Oh, let's upgrade.
Uh, you.
Jun!
Jun, you earned your place here.
You may become an apple.
And, uh, where's our berry, blueberry?
Blueberry, berry?
Blueberry?
Snizzle.
Snizzle, I need you to become at least a strawberry.
At least.
We don't need any more blueberries.
They're too cheap.
I see that golden pear.
Oh, yeah.
Let's get the hole back in the middle so that I'm not, like,
fighting to collect my money at the end.
Okay.
Get my money!
Where's the money?
Show me the money.
Get my money.
All of my money.
Miss not even a single penny.
Okay, I think that's all of it.
Sledgehammer!
Oh, I thought we were in the jungle.
In the jungle.
No, we're camping!
How cute!
We also have this puzzle.
You know what?
Let's start doing this.
Oh, okay.
Let's, like, do this puzzle.
Not even think about...
Dang it.
Oh, I lost out on today.
Oh, you could only do it once a day!
Okay, that's fine.
That's okay.
That's alright.
That's fine.
You do camp.
I forgot to get the stars again.
It's time to start eating the rest of this camp area.
Alright.
Oh, here's our sledgehammer.
Thank you.
Focus on breaking down these walls today.
Oh, I didn't even notice that it was time I didn't even
notice it was time for for Ben I'm glad that this game is
like creepy but not too like I didn't want anything overly
scary you know what I mean like a like a creepy vibe is
totally exactly the kind of vibe I wanted today so I'm
feeling I'm like hmm yeah Barry is was my producer on miss
rainbows berry patch the show I created and star in.
The show was in trouble, financially and critically.
I saw the writing on the wall, heard the rumblings from the
studio.
I knew I was on the chopping block.
Whoa.
Interesting.
Yeah, yeah!
All right.
Wow, look at this area.
Wow.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll get lucky.
I don't want our guys to like disappear, but...
Oh wait, I should probably move this.
You start going this way, over here.
Golden apple.
It's so cute!
and then also um where's my sledgehammer here we'll start
knocking down the rest of the walls the area is so big now
it's crazy it's crazy
always we got the password no wait this is not the password
because the password was four digits And wait, it was also
just letters.
You think it's bear?
No, it was four.
Oh my god.
What if it's June?
June owns this place.
June runs this place.
You also only...
Oh, no, you don't...
I was gonna say you only get one try.
B-E-R-I.
June.
Hmm.
Maybe B-U-R-Y, like, Barry?
That was a good, good, good, good choice.
Good, uh, idea.
Destroy the gnomes and their humble little families and
homes.
What was that one game?
Oh my gosh.
I got really into it too.
It had gnomes in it.
And it was also like a creepy kind of comfy.
You were in like...
Wow!
Oh wait, I missed them.
I'm not making any money.
Oh, the blitz is ready!
Let's move the hole like here.
Let's do the same thing that I did before.
Okay.
Blitz, blitz, blitz, blitz, blitz!
Yeah!
Okay, we did it.
At least.
The hole grows larger.
Oh shoot.
Oh, can I even collect all of this?
Huge, uh, huge hole.
The hole is ginormous.
Nice.
what is out there you see that oh thank you yes please send
the money over my way thank you very much for some reason i
almost was like okay time to go to bed and walk into the
hole
28 000
oh yeah the the bibble unlock the bibble surround yourself
and a bibble to float.
The day length.
Okay, I'm going to do that first.
And then we'll save for something maybe else.
Because day length also makes it so that we get more more
time to oh my gosh.
Decrease the everything.
Actually, it's kind of awesome.
Alright, let's go that this way.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we should upgrade some of our buddies soon.
Hi, Mito.
Hello!
Are you guys ready for some...
Barry's suckin' action?
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, let's do this, too.
Eyeball?
Is it eyeball?
Oh my god, I have to keep going.
What?
Oh, I don't know if I remember the rest.
I have to do the entire thing.
Oh my god, we knocked over the tree and then thing crazy um
no
i don't know no okay b pot eyeballs okay i'm not gonna
remember i'm not gonna remember i think oh thank you
i think that's all the cash money i want to get that it
seems like you like It looks like you unlock a star, but
maybe it's a special star.
Maybe it's worth a lot.
Oh.
Okay.
Blitz, Barry.
Barry, Blitz.
All movement range.
I'll hold off for now.
Decide what I want to do.
Big stars!
Please.
My gun.
my aim okay uh whatever uh let's go over here like in here
yeah and let's let's upgrade some guys as well uh I have
almost 200 who are you Zana congratulations you get an up
you get a you get a promotion oh I need to upgrade this guy
bad bad bad
where's uh here's my star this is the map is so huge now
it's so hard to collect all the berries where are you you
you again snizzle again snizzle
okay i'm trying to i'm attempting a tree at the moment It
appears.
All right, let's try this real quick again.
So it was eyeball, eyeball.
Honey, or teapot?
That's not the teapot.
Teapot.
Oh, I found the other half of the bee.
Okay.
Bee, bee.
Okay, we will get this.
We'll get this tomorrow.
We can do this tomorrow.
Trust, trust, trust, trust, trust.
Come here, come here.
Yeah!
Eat them up!
Yes!
Oh my god, the tree is like so in the way.
Oopsie.
I got greedy.
I got greedy!
Let's do my vacuum capacity.
And then next we can get the whole range.
All right.
Good job, stars!
Let's go over here.
Let's get these guys on their little table.
Gnomes' lives are worth so much.
Golden apple.
Golden pear!
Even better.
All right, blitz.
Maybe next.
Oh my god, tree.
What happened?
In them up, in them up, in them up.
Do you guys see what I mean though about how like addicting
this game is to watch?
Like it's just so like...
I just love watching number go up and everything.
It's just so fun.
Big thing.
Everything happening.
It's like so stimulating.
I feel like this is real.
Like if Cocomelon were, you know, V-Tuber Cocomelon.
No way.
Oh my god, I almost pushed it in.
Did I push it in?
Oh, hell yeah.
Okay.
Do I have enough time to do the puzzle?
I hope so.
This?
Ah!
Oh,
oh!
Maybe I shouldn't have broken that.
Wait.
Collect one black star.
Oh, maybe I...
Maybe that was a mistake.
That was kind of spooky.
I think I'm actually gonna upgrade my auto pickup.
They don't stop coming and they don't stop coming.
So many stars!
Who can we upgrade?
Who needs an upgrade?
Everybody is...
Apples right now?
Most everybody, except Elbow, I think.
Who is that?
Zina!
You get a promotion!
Oh, uh, let's go get this treat.
Actually, let's go get this happy little gnome family.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh my god, I almost fell in the hole.
Well, that was kind of freaky.
Good thing nothing happened from it.
Maybe?
That was freaky.
We destroyed them.
Oh my god, so many apples over here.
So this, always add first.
Maybe this is connected to that.
So maybe it's like...
Okay, well that will be a tomorrow activity.
That will be a tomorrow activity for sure.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Can we
get it?
Can we get the slide?
Oh no!
It was so close!
That's insane.
Come on.
Come on, Gabe.
Give me that.
Dang it.
Okay, hold on.
Let's look at this real quick.
Before we get consumed.
Always add first.
Okay, so to the right is plus two.
And this is...
So if it's like...
If we go two two.
like what one two then minus then one then that would be
wait i'm thinking wait how okay plus plus plus so one two
then one then minus one two then plus two oh okay wait
My brain!
Okay.
My brain.
So it would be...
2.
So that's 4.
Then we do...
Minus.
Oh shoot, I forgot about the stars.
And then...
So now we're at 2.
Then we do just the plus 2.
Just 1.
Then we do, so we're at four, so we do minus three.
One, two, three.
There's so many stations.
How do I get to four?
Oh, wait, maybe minus one again?
Did that do it?
Was that right?
Wait, did I do it right?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know what I'm at.
I wish there was a number.
And that's reset.
I don't know.
We'll try again tomorrow.
My brain.
Hurt you in that one.
We'll try again tomorrow.
Can I get this guy right here?
Am I being able to?
The music is so funny.
Oh, oh, so close.
Yeah!
We got it.
Alright, nice.
Nice having a larger pickup range.
Even if it's just a little bit larger.
It's actually just a little bit larger.
You had it apart from the last part.
Needed to add before subtracting.
Oh, it did say always add first, didn't it?
Oh, we made 100,000 total.
Let's go.
Do more range.
Okay, okay, okay.
So, 2-2.
Oh, I forgot about those sticking stars.
Okay.
2-2.
Then minus 2.
So we're at two then plus one
we're at four so minus three one two three so now if i do
plus two
and then minus oh it worked
we got it For better or for worse, baby.
I should do the fountain.
Um, we'll do it the fountain tomorrow.
Because I've wasted a lot of time on, you know.
Uh, can we grab anything, though?
Well, the hole?
Let's try and grab this tree.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Yippee!
We did it!
Good job, team.
Good job.
What?
And this tree?
And not me?
Oh.
I need some more fruit, please.
Kashikoi!
We did not get this tree, but that's okay.
I wish there was a way to auto-collect all the money.
There should be a way to auto-collect all the money.
Oh, that's so nice, though.
I just realized that I could walk through certain...
thing sometimes, but I guess once it turns night, you
actually can walk through stuff except the bed.
Okie dokie.
What time is it?
What time is our collab?
Oh, it's an hour and a half.
Okay, cool.
I have time.
We're good.
My tea has gone cold.
I haven't even sipped it one.
We've
been absolutely locked in.
Wait, we can increase the duration.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, come here.
Come here, come here.
I like this soundtrack too, it's good.
Blitz!
Oh, wow, it's going a little.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah!
Ow!
Oh, a crow is larger.
Over here.
Over here, over here.
Like right here.
There we go.
Oh, we almost got this thing.
I don't even know you could get that thing.
Goodbye, little gnomes.
Tree, tree, tree, grab the tree, grab the tree, grab the
tree, grab the tree.
I like how this guy's like chilling with the star.
It's so cute.
Yay!
I'm so locked into this game.
Oh my gosh.
I think if I played this off stream, it's one of those
things that I would just sit here and like...
For like a long time and just play by myself.
You know?
Oh my gosh, it's so addicting.
It's so addicting.
We have 200 stars.
Let's see how much it is to upgrade.
Well, I guess we'll have to check tomorrow.
I want more tapes.
I want more tapes for the lore.
English only.
messages seem to be yeeted what why wait seriously should we
switch to emo to only mode that's so strange also this
password here don't know it yet we're trapped in no message
hole sorry i'm i feel like i've been neglecting you guys a
little bit i'm so obsessed with my own hole
Let's try this, Minto.
Seems to work fine.
Yes, I see.
I keep getting...
There are some messages that are...
Thanks for what has been a very fun stream, Minto.
Can you believe that no one else has made this pun yet?
I'm so clever and original.
You are.
We fixed the problem now, this.
Really?
Is that why some people have been speaking in other
languages?
strange now don't add an email and it seems to work okay oh
yeah yeah
why is uh youtube being so strange
curious let's let's what is bipple let's try the bipple
welcome to membership thank you hold space oh my god oh my
god oh my god wait i'm trying to
I'm gonna get eaten by the hole as it grows.
As I'm trying to...
Oh my god.
Alright, what do we want to get today?
What are we going to do today?
Brain?
Same thing we do every day, Pinky.
Make our hole bigger.
YouTube hates us.
Yeah, what a strange bug, huh?
The RV?
Let's get these little guys first.
Let's get these little guys.
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah, let's get the RV.
Let's get the RV.
And there.
Oh, wait.
I just was able to float.
I said hold space.
Whoa, what is this?
That looks like a pumpkin.
We haven't even reached pineapple status.
Holy cow.
Maybe they're gold versions.
That is my hypothesis.
Sick beat this.
The chat is so lively now.
It's like half-Nihongo.
Konichiwa.
Minasans.
No, no, we can get the trailer.
We can get the trailer.
Come on.
So close.
We got it.
No.
So close.
close, so stinking close.
Okay, we need to move the hole a little bit before I...
Nice-ul!
Almost nice-ul.
We gotta get the hole to move a little bit.
Can I... Wait, let's see.
Can I go up here at night?
Oh, I can't use it at night.
I wish to find more lore.
I'm looking for lore at the moment.
You think we've like eaten?
Oh no, they've built themselves a little fort.
They're like, don't eat me.
Don't eat me.
Maybe now I can collect my stuff.
Yeah.
Very good.
Okay.
Alright, so let's go to bed.
Stop.
Next time, this.
I love me, Totej, pero.
Oh my god.
What?
My thing does not hit so well at all, does it?
Okay.
Let's get, like, over here.
My tummy's starting to growl.
I honestly, I've lost all track of everything.
I think I...
What's that?
why are you making pudding at 3 a.m.
because i've lost all control of my afterlife that's me
right now but with my hole this this hole consumes me this
is a funny glitch you guys having to you guys having to
speak in other languages to be heard
no it's so close come on we can push it and then then over a
little?
Okay, hold on.
We pushed the RV up.
And then it's like sticking straight up now.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh, red star!
Wait, can I get it?
Can I get it?
Get it?
Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get
it, Get it, get it, get it.
Nice.
Yes.
Huge!
Oh my god.
There's, I can't, I can barely read my chat anymore.
That's it, that's it, that's it, that's it.
What in the rose and maiden?
YouTube is our friend, Dash.
It wants us to learn Japanese.
Or speak like a petulgeist, Romani, Conti desu?
What?
Who?
Huh?
This!
Gomen, Minto.
It's okay.
YouTube created the Tower of Babel.
Wow.
Minda...
Nihongo...
Super talking.
Half talking.
Toto-tomo...
Suba- what is it?
Suba- Shubara amazing.
Shubara amazing this.
Don't Nihonko Joju us.
Is there a Berry Blitz countdown?
Or cooldown?
Lower.
No.
Okay, we have- we gotta upgrade our guys.
I forgot that we could rewind.
We can- we- retains our Berry buddies?
Star orbs?
But it would reset our upgrades.
I thought YouTube just hated me.
I just wanted to say Minto-chan kawaiio.
25% permanent berry growth speed.
Oh!
We can get to the 50,000!
50,000 black flower to bush.
Oh my god.
Looks like 50% to 80% of messages are not showing.
What the heck?
Oh my god, wait.
I can't shoot.
I can't shoot at all.
Oh, let's try this.
This is... Oh.
So jazzy.
Uh, Apple?
Oh, interesting.
Oh, here.
Gold kiwi.
Beep.
Another
one.
Gold pear.
Wait, did I skip over pineapple?
I guess I did on accident.
I like how they make me money just on accident just by being
their cute little selves.
Beep.
Beep!
We gotta figure out that password, guys.
My put- Pulling in all-weather- all-nighter for work.
Yes.
Insomnia forever.
Sorry.
I said night and work all- YouTube is broken.
Why is YouTube broken all the time, Lazy?
I don't think we're gonna make it, yeah.
Beep, boop, boop More money?
More money, mo problems.
Words that kill this.
We persevered this.
Just add this to everything.
Taboon, Google vibe code this.
Small indie company, please understand this.
Mito, we haven't a serious problem.
Sorry, that was more French than German, probably.
Programming flaw.
Konnichiwa.
It's Dutch da yo.
I wonder if Pekko works.
I think any Japanese would work.
That's Dutch des.
Oh.
Sumi Masari.
I'm ignorant!
America Jean...
This?
Please!
My gun!
Let's get this tree.
I might call it soon though.
I'm starting to get pretty hungry, so I should eat before I
before I go to the next stream.
It's broken for the sake of improving the user experience
this super chat is filtering like crazy oh my gosh oh I
appreciate you guys trying to super chat nonetheless thank
you very much um yeah I'm starting to you know I was losing
my mind before but now I'm starting to lose oh I'm starting
to lose we got a krill AI this so true sorry that the
YouTube is always being so funky lately you guys I don't
want to switch to twitch but sometimes it feels be an easier
option even though oh my gosh i tried watching a twitch
stream today and i had actual i i can't i don't even know
how many minutes i think it was like five minutes worth of
ads it was egregious i was so angry desh
at least i could still say minto cuteo you could say that if
you so choose to let's get all my stuff I feel like I'm at
like a what's it called like a carnival
where did it go oh there it was you love me until you hate
YouTube you love me though you hate YouTube this this wait
what year is this is Rosen made in back I know everybody's
saying this and it feels like What was her name?
Uh...
Oh gosh, what were the twins' names?
Kusa.
Ugu desu!
Oh, sui sei seki!
And sui- sui- I'll- I've- The name I remember the mostest is
sui ginto.
Yay!
I think I will call it here though.
I'm gonna wake up.
Let's see if I can save the game.
Oh, quit the main menu.
I'm so hungry.
I'm gonna go eat.
Let's raid into the the Densetsu stream, which will be in a
in about one hour.
I can't even type anymore.
My brain is like you know, when you lose
when you lose everything all your I can't think anymore I
have to go eat my blood sugar is plummeting at an alarming
rate thank you everybody Utsubito Utsubito I will hopefully
see you in one hour thank you go wherever you go Minto even
if it's Twitch this YouTube has just been so crummy lately.
Sorry, go take you so much.
Hope your food is extra.
Or super yummy.
Try Princess, thank you.
Virulent, thank you.
YouTube issues aside.
This is really fun if you want to play another puzzle game.
With an all-consuming hole, give donut county.
I love consuming holes.
Or the holes that consume.
Not me consuming them.
What's up, everybody?
Bye bye!
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry that I ran away so fast.
I'm just so hungry.
So...
Thank you for the pig!
I'm just so hungry.
Hang- I'm gonna get it hangry if I don't eat it soon.